okay hello everyone we are here to do a
kind of science meets technology
discussion about
of
gravitation General activity
Wilson model
hypergraphs and related topics and we're
going to talk about uh some of
Jonathan's
work on uh developing function
repository entries
and so on for
doing
uh
general relativity calculations
basically on the basis of hypergraphy
writing and so on and I guess
um if we're lucky we will manage to uh
segue into some discussion about
actual practical astrophysical
experimental implications of our models
okay so Jonathan uh if I let's let's
sort of aim for I want to simulate the
Collision of two black holes
how do I where do I start okay so so
first thing to know is you know the the
sort of the the the the first class
objects in the in this whole framework
is metric tensor right so so pretty much
you know every other every other object
that you uh and every other function
that you would call in the gr framework
has at least one metric tensor object
attacked attached to it somehow
um so metric tensor if you if you pull
up the details you'll see the metric
sensor has a bunch of inbuilt metrics uh
already available and um you know we
have plans to expand that Library you
know it'll be hopefully it'll become
like a sort of axiomatic Theory type
function where yeah so hold on where is
this now so if you look at the details
section of the of the documentation
um then somewhere there okay yeah so
that's a table of all the all the
inbuilt metric tests we currently
support
okay so let's take you know occur with a
mass
right
so how do I then get so if you just call
metric tensor I mean if you just call
metric tensor and then and Cur it will
it will do the it will do the general
case of Cur
okay
look at this new tech
um
uh metric tensor oops very bad well it's
gonna fail though
okay what is this so that's now a
symbolic metric tensor object so you can
see by default it's like it's it's in
covariant form so both of its indices
are lowered
um and so you can look at its Matrix
representation if you just take that
thing and you call and you request
property Matrix representation
um
especially there's no autocomplete for
that
that can what the heck happened here
with this metric tensor turning blue
that I don't know that I don't think
that should happen
um well it's happening because you've
named a symbol and it's not in the
system context but except it shouldn't
be like that that should be a string
name
um because this whole object should be
a resource is that correct
well so the the the summary box uh is
not like the summary box should not have
metric is symbolic metric tensors it
does not have symbolic metric tenses its
first argument it has string metric
tensors its first argument okay I don't
understand that Jose do you happen to
know how that works on Nick
no I I don't know
can you make a note of that so we oh up
on that
the reason for that is so if you if you
have a function repository entry that
returns just like a summary box with the
symbolic name in it then it it look it
renders really ugly because it's contact
it will have some random context yeah
um so to get around that the the wfr
team said what you know the thing the
correct thing to do is just have this is
have the string name in the summary box
rather than
um well okay but so somehow the summary
box is breaking itself open that's a
separate issue Okay so we've got a
curmetric and
so now what can I do with this uh okay
so you I mean if you look at the full
properties of metric sensor you can see
the things you can do to it directly
um
but like so you know mostly this is just
different ways of visualizing and
Computing simple things you know you can
you can look at this you can look at the
space-time line element or you could uh
you know you can get you can extract out
pure functions that allow you to
um
I think it's just one element
I mean because in principle this doesn't
have to be a space time this could just
be an arbitrary metric right
um why does it say DS squared equals
as opposed to just this being the line
element
I mean it could just it could have the
DS squared be implicitous if if you
prefer well I just think then it's an
equation here this is not a line element
this is an equation
I know but you know I don't know usually
if you see someone say this is the line
element for Cur in a paper or something
like that's what they mean like maybe
they should say line element definition
or something as opposed to just line
element which I really think should just
be the actual
what do you think
sorry sorry yes I agree with Stephen it
will be more computable to have
something that um
is is one of the sides of this equation
okay okay fair enough
um
I mean for what it's worth the the
computable form of the line element
would be length pure function
I see
this the line element is supposed to be
a kind of symbolic thing where where
does that sorry you have so is it yeah
length it's the it's the last but three
or whatever of the
set of the properties
so now if you take that and you apply it
to a four Vector
um it will give you the length of that
four Vector incur
euclidean for that I mean the minkowski
fall back to her what kind of well you
know a full Vector with with minus plus
plus signature
thank you
what's data
sorry what's Theta
oh Theta is the angular coordinates
so oh I see I see I see because this is
it varies with the position it's not
it's exactly yeah it's a varies with the
radius and the position yeah so it has
only a cylindrical it has cylindrical
symmetry of some kind so it doesn't have
a Phi
precisely precisely and similarly if you
did angle pure function that would give
you a two argument pure function that
would allow you to compute the angle
between two four vectors okay
so this is the length of a vector at the
tangent space at that point yes
right
Okay so
one issue here I mean so this
the question of how to make a
lightweight repository is an interesting
question because that's what we really
need for this
um although what about these
parametrized ones how do they work in
Repository
do we have that issue with axiomatic
Theory well we do because we allow for
operator
um renaming oh that's right so it then
becomes an association yeah I mean that
was in the original design that was why
we decided against having it I think the
original plan was to have axiomatic
Theory be an entity store and the reason
we decided against that was because we
couldn't find a nice way of doing the
operator overloading this feels uh
similar to coordinate chart data and we
have the same issue there with
parameters
well I mean it's possible this should
actually be promoted one day to an
actual system function of some kind
um
it's kind of weird here I mean these are
some very standardized set of coordinate
systems aren't they like there's some
number of coval linear coordinate
systems and we have all of them so the
first statement
yes so yes these are their orthona
as opposed to
uh
know what that means why does that how
do I get the um the analog of the metric
or can I just ask for the metric
okay so in that case the metric is a
function
yes if you provide a third argument with
coordinates
um list XYZ
okay
um
let's see if I say
okay but toroidal coordinates for
example
I have to give a parameter here
Aubrey please report this is thirteen
three and it's pinking it's uh
this
uh suggestions bar gotta capture it all
reported
what the heck
what's the r doing here I think toroidal
a
what's this
I
don't know to be honest
I can follow up on that
what's going on here
okay well anyway so this is a model
what is the relationship between
coordinate charts I mean in in general
activity there are often multiple charts
characterizing a given metric is that
not true yes and so okay and this is
this is okay this is a genuine design
question so right now my
so okay to make this a little bit
concrete right if if you if you say if
you say metric tend to schwa's Shield or
something by default it will give you
the shield metric in short coordinates
okay
um but you can also say something like
metric tensor isotropic trust children
it will give you the structural metric
and isotropic coordinates or you can say
um uh you know what else do we I think
from Finkelstein coordinates yeah yeah
exactly so you can you could say
Eddington Finkelstein if you wanted to
so okay so this is I can ask for
Ellington Finkelstein which is not just
a metric but it's also a coordinate
system for the metric is that correct
right and so by default that's that
gives you any that gives you the schlotz
field metric in Eddington tinklestein
coordinates
so it's okay on the one hand there's
something a little bit uncomfortable
about treating these uh Matrix
representation
there's something a little bit
uncomfortable about treating these
things as separate metric tenses when
they are like
diff as you say different coordinate
charts for the same geometry
um my reason for having them be separate
metric oh be treated to separate metric
tenses is because they are in some sense
different manifolds right the the the
um you know
there are bits of the like if you were
to plot the isotropic Schultz job metric
and you were to plot the shots you know
the the you know the engine Finkelstein
version of the straw metric and you were
to plot the schwartsfield coordinates
version of the shortstop metric they
don't look the same you know on the
interior they have different geometries
um and so my feeling was it it makes
even though they are just just different
coordinate charts it makes sense to
treat them as different metrics well
wait a minute physically
if you could probe if you could
penetrate The Event Horizon would they
be in fact different
well the the I don't think that's a
really meaningful question right because
the Schwartz child coordinates only
apply to an observer who is infinitely
far away from the black hole
distribution so in other words what
you're saying is
it's kind of like an interpolating
function where in the region where the
thing is supposed to be valid they agree
right and then it goes Bonkers elsewhere
right I mean like an extreme version of
that is you know we we support the
crystal Sakura's metric right which is
oh you know the crystal extension of the
shortest child metric and so again that
that's a that's a very
evocative example of it yeah you know
where where the where they are both
defined it agrees with the traditional
metric and shortstop coordinates but
there are many bits where Schwartz child
is not defined but where it is defined
in Crystal psychology what's this plus
minus one doing uh so that's because you
can have both in-going and outgoing
editing the physical science coordinates
so if you say in-going editing
Finkelstein that will change to just be
a plus if you change it to outgoing
editing pickles don't change it to just
be a minus
okay
uh we have the same thing with things
like in-going and outgoing coordinates
and so on
um what I should be doing for this
toroidal thing
oh wow
so what does euclidean mean there and
how does that relate to
what we're doing
what is the role of euclidean there
so
so we have metrics that could live on on
the sphere or or or different dimensions
Etc so this is a case in which there are
other possibilities I have to check with
the die and and it seems that that we
need a full specification in this case
but this notion of euclidean here
in a sense for all of these we could
have said minkowski in addition to the
I'm confused so coordinate chart data
as compared to Eddington Finkelstein
here that's the same type of thing
toroidal versus Eddington winklestein is
so confusing this is the labeling
ancient physical signs the labeling of
the spot Shield manifold so to speak
so there are two different things here
so so in the in the coordinator data
case we support coordinates for the
sphere and for the flat space with the
cleaning space
in in any dimension in relativity
the the coordinates and the space are
are so the metric and and space are are
mixed
and so
it it's it's a bit
less clean in in the general
alternativity case
I think we we have to say sphere
and and total completing just spherical
so I don't know why
I see
it also completed the spherical but
maybe it doesn't support
so not all coordinate systems are
supported for the sphere of course but
um right and toroidal is pretty weird on
the sphere there's some Weird homocopy
thingy thingy going on there right so um
again I could track polo for example
here
hmm
I'm confused
okay
so but for example we have stereographic
for the sphere as well
this is a sphere to change to a sphere
even though the autocomplete is a
spherical which we need to look at
okay
all right so say again what you were
saying about the fact that
in
I mean because
one could expect somewhere here and and
Jonathan's probably going to explain you
know that there could be a base here of
four dimensional minkowski space
it's basically the thing
exactly but the problem is okay so so
um and I guess when you say the base is
important space I guess you mean we're
just treating this as a you know as a
minus plus plus manifold
right
so a luxury that we do not have in the
hypergraph case
or really in the relativity case if
we're being honest right like it so if
you take one of these metrics you can
say for instance
um you know uh lorenzian conditions and
it will tell you what conditions on the
coordinates are needed in order to
guarantee that that happens but like you
know it if you pass the um if you pass R
equals 2m in the you know in the
shortstop geometry then it's no longer
laurencian
what does that mean
uh okay so that means that there's no
coordinate there are no uh you know
ranges of coordinates in which that is
truly lorenzian
how can that be
I don't understand that uh you might
okay we we can we can maybe look at that
in a sec but okay look at this for the
structural case those are the coordinate
conditions you'd need
all right those first two conditions are
the same
yes
it hasn't released those out you you
could you can say reduce on that but
okay
and how could this not be true
uh well I mean in principle greater than
zero is there a theta equals zero case
uh yes and and the metric does become
singular there
huh
Okay so
so coming back for a moment to the
structure of coordinate chart data so
that's trying to separate the geometry
from the coordinates in which that
geometry is being expressed Central
activity we could why didn't this work
it probably would have done if you
didn't have complete so the the the the
symbol all the coordinate symbols are
maximally formalized if you okay if you
change the second argument of Schwartz
child and just make it be and have that
argument be a list say tra1a2 or
something
why should a care they're formalized
here
I mean I understand why it makes any
difference it's just they're just
symbols foreign
if you try it with with non-formalized
symbols I I I'm just I I don't know I'm
I'm that's what do you think that's the
condition well how many variables are
there here uh four
oh and you might need to chain oh sorry
try that okay you may also need to say
it in short Shield change uh change that
to a list of schwarzgold comma something
for the mass
there we go that's just bizarre
what the heck
why does it care
I mean and I think it needs to go into
those are formal symbols right so if I
look at the input form they might
actually I think they're stringed
they're stringified formal symbols
I had my reasons
why the heck do they have to be
stringified
well that's going to break a lot of
things so that's highly undesirable with
that stringified
so it'd be nice to not have the only
stringified in the way that they get
presented
um they're not stringified in the like
in the in the intestines of the function
all the computations are done on
non-stringified versions
okay but fine but when they come out
like this we got to be able to evaluate
them
right I mean I can have them return a
non-stringified form it's yeah
it seems highly desirable okay in any
case all right so where do we go from
Okay so
these metrics are named metrics uh-huh
and just so I'm trying to understand it
you know in the modern world of machine
learning for everything and llms and all
that kind of thing you know I can make a
reasonable picture of a of a rabbit in
3D by just using some text prompt
is it consumable that I could create a
general relativity metric from a text
prompt
an analytical one
the no no probably not I mean just like
I can say you know if I say three black
holes
foreign
gravitationally bound
I this is this is going to be
unbelievably scary and ridiculous but
but um
uh I I doubt it I mean I I don't I don't
know enough about llms but I
no I mean this is somewhat ridiculous
but but
it's cool it's it's cool and amusing but
but my point is what people are going to
want is an easy way to create initial
conditions for things yes
um
yes that much I agree with and so I mean
if we want to talk about initial
conditions we probably need to talk
about ADM decomposition which is the
function that really does that all right
all right but so but this is generating
analytical condition analytical metric
tensors and things exactly so so and if
you so if you wanted to do so an initial
condition would be a metric tensor
object but it would be a
three-dimensional rather than a
four-dimensional you know it would have
one dimension
for time okay but so so just so you know
let's say I'm trying to invent a great
new solution to the Einstein equations
right
actually for each one of these
presumably there's an energy momentum
tensor that goes with it right okay so
so if you take one of these metrics that
you've just I mean you happen to have
used only vacuum metrics right so that's
pretty easy we can just take one of
those metric sensors you can say uh you
can call resource function um solve
vacuum Einstein equations
on any of these
on the metric tensor on the metric
sensor and then you probably want to say
com oh okay you probably want to say
comma zero to say that you want um zero
cosmological constant otherwise it will
assume non-zero cosmological constant
and then it won't work
okay so it's telling you that that is an
exact solution to the field equations
how do I tell that from this
uh which is exact solution true
I don't understand this output I mean
normally I would expect
I'm I'm a bit confused here so this is
saying
this thing so for example let's say I
put in the so it's arguable that this
thing should not be called solve it
should be called reduce or something but
I so what it's doing is you give it a
metric tensor object it will say it will
determine hey does this just directly
solve the Einstein you know the Einstein
equations exactly
um and if not are there conditions we
could use that we could impose that
would mean that they do that it does
okay yeah so in that case if you if you
get rid of the zero
there we go okay so it's it's a solution
but it assumes four field equations
so if you if you extract if you say if
you extract out field equations from
that
hmm
can you for example compute the Einstein
tensor
yes uh yeah so so if you call resource
function Einstein Einstein tensor on a
metric sensor then you can compute yeah
because then using the Einstein
equations you could say this is equal
modular constant to T menu
yeah right exactly yeah which which is
what solventions and equations does in
generality so yeah if you take it so
it's the ancient tensor if you say so
you can call that and say you know
reduced Matrix representation or
something that will say that will show
you the Matrix representation of that
tensor with all um sort of known
algebraic equivalences imposed
reduced Matrix what representation
reduce Matrix representation just like
so you can call Matrix representation or
you can call reduce Matrix
representation depending on whether you
want it to be Auto simplified or not
so that's the engine tensor for
for the good old metric and then you
could you could set that equal to
something right so so you could so then
you can say stress energy tensor oh okay
so that should return a zero Matrix
uh Schwartz has a w yeah so it does
lovely
okay so what about something with so
this has a big cosmological term play
but what about well actually so the
girdle metric is really a um it's a it's
a dust metric
um naturally
so if you say resource function stress
energy tensor
okay so then so
so we have again we have a bunch of
inbuilt I mean we have a small library
of involved stressing okay that's not
going to work um you need to give it so
first of all the first argument you need
to give it an actual stress energy
distribution
um so uh that could be
I mean for the girdle case you'd
probably want it to be dust or something
um it's too complicated I I think I get
the point but let's not get uh let's not
get pulled into this
oh yeah
I mean I think I think well I'm
understanding I mean what we're looking
at roughly is
we've got
you know a bunch of name metrics but now
if we ask the question
of all
I mean
oh and you were now talking about the
ADM the composition but as far as the
for all time metrics which is what these
are aren't they yes
so
just a sort of a
a learning moment what for all time
metrics I mean aren't there like I don't
know Bianchi type something or other
universes and things that represent
sort of uh with given symmetry for all
time
metrics or am I not right about that
uh I think so
um I mean like if what you're talking
about is yeah you can certainly
parameterize like classes of metrics
I mean the Bianchi universe is a one
such parameterization
right
is there a place where somebody has like
collected
endless
sort of Exact Solutions
I know there are books that are that
have been that have tried to collect
these things but I don't know if Jose
has
more information yes those books are the
main references some people have tried
to collect them
um computationally but
um well there's there's not an
accessible database what you can go
well you mean you mean they've tried to
collect them but haven't succeeded or
they've tried to collect them and they
keep them to themselves or what what's
they are adaptive to some I mean because
there are multiple packages for tensor
computations they are collections
adapted to one of these
um
packages
so like for exact are there is there a
collection we don't have an exact we we
have I mean we have notebooks with
examples with collections of examples
but we don't have a systematic
collection of metrics
it has been proposed but nobody did it
so far
well is there something that we could
get
you know
is there
is this a project for some
for somebody
to go and try and collect and then how
many are there are there like 500 are
there 200 how many are there roughly
there are families here the stress
energy tenses go ahead
um
they can be very strange and and
sometimes they are they are classified
by uh algebraic properties so it's not
that they correspond always to physical
scenarios
um
okay but so for example
I mean like the failure of a solution to
the helium atom in analytical form
I suspect for more than one black hole
you're out of luck for anything article
is that a true statement
certainly no analytical solution is
known yeah and it's widely believed that
they don't exist well I don't think
anyone I don't think
the the 21st Century Class of special
functions yes right
it's either going to hit the wall of
undecidability or there's going to be a
22nd century instead of um you know of
special functions but so certainly in
ADM decomposition we have you can
produce a symbolic metric sensor that
corresponds to a to a black hole
Collision you know to a binary black
hole Collision
um but you know it it involves things
that you need to determine by
essentially by numerical differential
you know by doing numerical integration
all right so if I go here to ADM
decomposition I'm going to start seeing
yeah so if you go in here again we so we
have a subset of the um
a subset of of the things in in metric
tensor sort of initial condition
libraries so if you say ADM
decomposition Schwartz shows or
something you don't get the you don't
get the you don't get the same shots job
metric that you would have got from
um from metric sensor you get a sort of
a more underdetermined version of it
where you where you only know the
structural geometry on the initial space
like hypersurface yes
um so if you now say ADM if you if you
take that thing and you say uh like
space-time metric tensor
as opposed to spatial metric sensor it
will give you the symbolic metric sensor
objects which you can then say Matrix
representational
so uh it's pretty clear it's pretty easy
if you put that in Matrix form by the
way
just for visual
purposes
uh but yeah so you can see if you look
at the three by three sub-matrix apart
from the first and second you know first
row First Column that three by three sub
Matrix is just that that's the geometry
of the initial structural hypersurface
that's just a spherically symmetric 3
geometry and these other things you have
to solve for exactly so those are then
the gauge variables Alpha B to one V2
b23 those are your lapse and shift
I see
but so in actuality given that initial
data that you've got there there is a
solution that is just the four full
dimensional full four-dimensional
structural solution yes and so although
this function isn't in the function
repository yet it is in the GitHub
repository um and so so maybe when I
when we switch over later I can show you
so that there's we have functions we're
doing for solving the ADM equations in
generality and so there's a there's a
fairly easy way that you can you can
sort of you know starting from just this
initial hypersurface version you can
reconstruct the analytical form of the
Schwartz job metric from that just by
figuring out what what you know what
constraint what conditions need to hold
in order for the constrained equations
to be satisfied and so on and that's the
only solution yeah the the
four-dimensional short shelter the only
solution given that initial data uh
exactly or not the modulo some notion of
equivalence
um so the the you still remember you
still have a lot of coordinate free you
know you still have a lot of gauge
Freedom there are many ways you can
slice up the struts job geometry and so
you it won't always lead you to the
exactly the same form of the metric
sensors you would get in the analytical
version right so you're saying there are
different foliations corresponding to
different which will give you different
analytical forms for the
four-dimensional metric tensor because
essentially the time coordinate is you
know the relationship at the time
coordinate well I'm not quite sure given
that you define the space like
hypersurface the initial space like
hypersurface yeah
subsequent space like hyperservices
could be tipped progressively tipped
relative to that one right the fact that
we're defining different Notions of
simultaneity so the alpha function there
is telling you what's the time like
distance between the neighboring space
like hyposurfaces and the beta 1b2 beta
3 is telling you effectively how do I
relabel the spatial coordinates between
the different hyper surfaces
um okay and then if you if you look at
if you go back to the ADM decomposition
documentation in the full list of
properties you'll see we have we have
support for a bunch of inbuilt gauge
conditions
um which effectively correspond to
different foliation choices so okay
let's say that's the those are the
initial data but in here so yeah things
like so maximal slicing condition
harmonic slicing condition one plus log
slicing condition etc those are all
different conditions you can put on the
lapse function that tell you how you
foliate the space time and then things
like normal coordinate conditions or
harmonic coordinate conditions those are
conditions on the shift Vector that tell
you how you relabel the coordinate the
spatial coordinates
okay okay okay great
all right let's let's
dive below space so to speak and
understand how we can
um the things you've done for building
these other hypergraphs and so on right
okay so for that you'll want the
function discrete hypersurface
decomposition and again there are as
with any of these there there are more
in the pipeline that will be in wfr soon
um
a discrete type of surface decomposition
yeah I know oh sorry
I'm hoping that the search system will
we only have one function with Hyper
surface in its description
wow cool okay
so what this thing does is it you you
give it a symbolic metric tensor and it
will slightly it will do a space-time
foliation of it and it will produce a
sequence of hypographs that correspond
to different slices in that foliation
where those typographs are not
necessarily related by by hypography
writing
uh so in the case where you are solving
for the thing
um you know numerically they will be
they will be related so essentially what
we're doing is
um you know it's
all right the key Insight is that sort
of adaptive generalized adaptive mesh
refinement is really just typographic
writing with a very weird event
selection function right your event
selection function is saying
progressively refine your course on the
hypograph at these points based on some
Criterion that has to do with you know
uh curvature tensors and whatever
um and so internally you you know
formally you can think of that as being
a hypography writing system just with a
slightly odd event selection function
well let me understand that for a second
so you've got an initial
essentially triangulation of space
yeah it's not it's not it's not a train
it's less topologically structured than
a triangulation but can we see what that
initial one would look like here uh yeah
so okay so if you take uh all right so
so that particular ADM metric you know
that that's underdetermined right that
has Alphas betas and things if you take
schwarzjold
okay
with those symbolic parameters
uh well those are the coordinates that
there should be no symbolic parameters
if we want a numerical thing okay fine
then what does this mean
so that that's saying okay that's
telling you which part of the geometry
you want to decompose so it's saying
between time between zero and one radial
coordinate between zero and four and the
Theta coordinate between minus pi and Pi
then we're saying we want 200 vertices
and with an initial sort of refinement
scale of 1.5
okay so so how do I get the just the
initial refinement not the T equals zero
refinement uh so I believe hang on let
me just quickly double check uh the
right way to do this sorry it's
um I I believe you can just put in a
Time Value into
uh the property but I I just want to
double check that I was like
okay but basically what this is I
hopefully we'll get some visualization
in a moment okay so all right so okay if
you were to just if you were to take
that and just say
um uh what would you want you want Polar
graft Evolution colored
holograph Evolution colored yes
so polar graph colored will show you the
final hypersurface
only polygraph Evolution will show you
all the hyper surfaces including both
the initial and final forms uh right now
there isn't an option A straightforward
option to get just the initial one but
maybe I should add that
um let's let's just get fewer of them
and then we can get just then we'll pull
out the initial one right
there we go let's get fewer of them and
just cut the initial one
uh so so if you give it a if in that
property if you give it a list rather
than saying polygraph Evolution color
you say the list polygraph Evolution
colors comma however many steps you want
to go
if you say zero you would just get the
initial I think okay fine list or or
just the zero there uh no list list and
then zero
why is this taking so long I mean it's
isn't it doing 200 steps I don't need
you to do something no no no that's
doing 200 vertices oh
okay I'm not sure why that happens but
there we go
okay 200 of us is what's the 1.5 that's
the that's the initial refinement level
so if you increase so you would get a
denser you know a more densely connected
typograph for higher values of that
higher values the higher values
so what is the actual computation going
on here is it a bunch of an algebra what
what is it is it going to be faster if I
don't assuming the big GPU and so on
it's a fair AI it's it's largely linear
algebra
a multi-linear algebra I guess
all right so this is
I mean at some level I should be able to
reconstruct I mean the traditional
picture of the of the schwatch solution
with um you know
um in a manifold so to speak this should
limit to the manifold somehow right and
if you say coordinatized polygraph
colors or something then you'll get
you'll get that yeah you you'll get to
see that with the vertex coordinates
and the vertex coordinates here this is
projecting into
I mean it's a 3D object yeah so it gets
projected onto a plane you effectively
the by default whatever the third
coordinate is is going to be suppressed
so that is effectively the embedding
diagram for the that's a you know a
discretization of the embedding diagram
for the response job metric
Okay so what's happening
okay there's nothing in the inside
yeah so it gets truncated at a point at
a you know beyond a certain point so if
you were to you know if you were to
extend this indefinitely it would it
would you know that interior bit would
go on forever uh because it's that's
that's where the coordinate Singularity
is
okay but let me understand this I mean
why
in the far field let's let's imagine
that instead of a schwartzelt thing here
I was just doing flat space for my
metric
right
what will be the name for the flat space
so you buy the flat space metric I just
want to see what this hypography
composer produces uh you'd want
minkowski
okay so okay so here instead of this I
want to use minkowski yeah you may get
some I I'm actually curious you may get
some weird division by zero error I I I
I don't I don't really know so I just
say minkowski here
uh yes
and then what for these parameters uh
you want I mean you probably want x y z
or something uh TTX parameters no no
four I'm just saying I'm just saying
that you know the ra1a2 doesn't make
sense uh T should be the first
okay
okay so now I want to do the same thing
here
I don't know whether I want that a
what I want to do with the TRX I won't
say yeah so t01 is fine you probably
want X between I don't know minus two
and two or something y between minus two
and two
um and then you you don't want Polar
graph you want Cartesian graph to
indicate you're using a Cartesian
coordinate system
well that's a big graph
IC I mean that yeah that you may want oh
you may no you may want to reduce the um
the 2.5 make that one or something but I
don't know
that may be the problem
okay
so why are there two holes here
uh I suspect that's a discretization
artifact if you run it again those
should not be there I mean although
there may be holes but they'll be
different holes
okay
okay so then what I want to understand
is this thing here
if I look at flat space okay fine so
it's some weird thing there
yeah
because I remember the discretization
process is essentially is fundamentally
random right we're doing a Plus on it's
a Plus on point process
so we're making okay fine okay so here
if I look at the GDC balls around these
points I would confirm that this is
indeed flat mankowsky space indeed yeah
but I mean this is pretty messy
can I can I re-render this as the say
do you want it to be coordinatized it
doesn't have to be coordinatized right
well let me now make a coordinate first
okay but let's let's make it not tubular
and let's just let's just see what's
going on let's make um
uh graph
Edge Style
Arrow like gray or something
it's going to do exactly Oops why didn't
that work
it's a list
sorry
okay it ignored my Edge Style
I'm trying to understand I'm trying to
see what this looks like because I'm
trying to see this looks much more
densely connected
okay let's not let's see but it but it's
only densely connected because you made
it that way so to speak right if you
lower the one it will be less so
okay so this purports to be flat space
even though this rendering
doesn't make it look terribly flat
right
well it's flattened two Dimensions but I
don't know whether that's the right
thing is that
it should be flat these are meant to be
two-dimensional projections of the hyper
surfaces
okay but but I mean this is kind of the
null experiment this is flat space time
right supposedly
and so if I were to evolve flat space
time it should not change
um right
but yet if I evolve the hypergraph
corresponding to something which is
non-flat
I expect evolution of some kind
right I mean you'll still get quote
unquote evolution in the flat Space Case
right it's just that you know it'll be
change the Platinum I I got it enough
that yeah
okay but so in the case of the black
hole solution the single shot solution
yeah what I expect again
in the evolutionists that will preserve
that course Grange virtual solution is
that true that's true yeah
doesn't work
uh yeah I mean you you sort of you see
that above right like the
the graphs they flap around a bit but
the the course properties are
I think you I think you did a brief
Evolution yeah
um okay so what's a non-stationary
solution well it's a non-stationary
initial condition
two black holes
two black holes yeah we can do but
that's complicated
um flrw with a you know with a dynamical
scale factor would be a a simple
um a simple example of a non-stationary
thing although that's a bit boring
because it's sort of conformally flat
[Music]
um
like it's not very exciting to look at
what does it mean in these pictures that
it's conformally flat
I mean it will it will just look like
flat space but growing
I see oh basically
okay
all right so and what you found is that
for a quite a wide class of hypography
writings you get things that's coarse
grain correctly
as as long as you impose the right event
selection function right and that's
that's really where I mean in a sense
it's you know it's a that's that's where
we cheat so to speak
um
selection function is defining
foliations or what yeah exactly and so
and so we we just we choose there's
enough freedom in how we select the
events that we can just say well of
course number find the hypograph you
know apply in other words apply the
hypography writing rules in accordance
with
um you know where the height regions of
high or low curvature are
but is there not something wait a minute
the sort of naturally occurring event
selection function if we were to make
essentially a token event graph out of
this yeah would involve more events in
places where there are in a sense a
higher density of of vertices wouldn't
it yes and so in the continue in the
Continuum limit that would correspond to
um normal coordinate conditions and gd6
slicing and the problem with that is
that it will that will stretch in
anything in any space time where there's
a singularity like uh or multiple like
like with frost chills it will mean that
your like your foliation you know your
the slices of your affiliation will get
hugely stretched around those
singularities and so it you know it's
it's actually it's not a particularly
good uh gauge choice
so and the reason for that is it's it's
like the fact that the black hole never
actually forms the outside Observer or
something the time is infinitely
stretched that's yeah and and very
concretely it means that the that the
vast majority of your rewrites in in
fact in the limit 100 of your rewrites
are going to be concentrated around the
Event Horizon
walk me through that so that that's
because what that's the intuition behind
that the rewrites
so because that's just where you have
the highest density of hyper graph edges
right no I realize that but I mean in
terms of understanding time dilation in
terms of rewrites yeah
right so what's actually happening so so
that's that's corresponding to the
statement that an observer would so the
the number of rewrites you would need to
cross the Event Horizon would be
infinite in other words you know sort of
and the interpretation of that is that
to an outside Observer
it takes an infinite time for something
to cross the Event Horizon yeah
precisely
but why isn't there a co-moving
why is what matters I see it's because
you're pinning somehow to asymptotic
Infinity you're you're making some well
explain this is that because I mean no
so if you did this with in a different
Corner if you didn't do an insurance
child coordinates then that wouldn't be
then then you know then you're seeing
the hypograph evolution as observed by
you know some an in-falling observer in
Eddington Finkelstein governance or
something then it's a different then
it's different than that then there
aren't then nothing special happens at
the Event Horizon you don't see a sudden
spike in hypography rights there
I see
so the passage of more time corresponds
the perceived passage of more time is
the doing of more hyper Godfrey rights
right
right how should we understand the fact
that
let's see the number of rewrites
there is an intrinsic number of rewrites
that happen
but to different observers they can
Bunch up the foliations or spread them
out in such a way that they change the
number of rewrites that happen per
moment of foliation time that a fair way
to say it yeah I think so I mean so the
the important point is that with any of
these space times you know the causal
graph extends indefinitely
and so you can slice it apart in ways
that take you know infinite time to
reach certain parts or you know infinite
numbers of slices to reach certain parts
or you can slice it apart in ways to
take a finite number of you know finite
amount of time to reach certain parts
but in so doing you're producing
essentially infinite you know uh causal
Edge distances between those slices
can we generate the causal graph for
this Evolution uh yes but unfortunately
that that functionality is not yet in
the function repository um that's you
know that's in the pipeline
um
but so that causal graph what you're
saying is these different coordinate
systems sample the same causal graph
that is the same cause of graph in the
end but they're sampling it differently
right exactly exactly and so the and so
the the sort of the um the default event
selection function which is as I say the
gd6 lysine normal coordinate conditions
cases for vadm uh is essentially the one
where if you like we have you know the
the all the slices are just distance one
away from each other in some sense right
um yeah and so inevitably that's not
going to reach the you know the parts of
the causal graph that are infinitely far
away it's not going to reach that
infinite it's not going to reach those
in finite time
but the parts of the course of graph I
mean to a photon it's just tooling along
in some sense the causal graph
with
no time passing so a photon
if I'm not mistaken so a photon can
successfully reach these distant parts
of the causal graph
uh yeah as as can as can a massive
object right it just but the point is
that the coordinate system
and therefore you know the gauge choice
and therefore the foliation observed by
those things is not going to be the
default you know distance one foliation
yeah I get it but so to an observer
let me think about this for a second
um
so different relativistic Observers
I mean I'm kind of wondering about many
observers that are based on actually
doing rewriting for the Observer
does that make any sense so in other
words rather than from the outside
saying here's how I slice the causal
graph the Observer is seeing these
slices yeah asking the question could
there actually be a little critter
sort of being updated inside the the
where you identify a piece of causal
Graphics this is the Observer
right no I mean I think we should
absolutely do that because you know it's
useful for physics project purposes and
other things the reason that's not
supported yet
at least from my perspective is that
it's so there's a pretty well defined
way of specifying you know continue
engage choices and then discretizing
them we don't yet really have a way a
systematic way of specifying discrete
gauge choices
um without just kind of straight up you
know giving the giving the answer change
in the causal graph I know that this has
been this has been the long running
three plus year story of kind of how do
you label you know it's depth first it's
breadth first what are the reasonable
choices of orderings
right Nick I think if you if Nick is
still with us here I think you've
thought about this a bit
ostensibly here
okay
and but I think this is a
this is an Old Chestnut problem yeah
of what are the Observer reasonable
choices of foliations
right I mean one one question is how
much inspiration can we take from the
ADM case you know like so in other words
how General are those coordinate systems
or are those gauge choices like does it
make sense to use harmonic slices that's
very technical ADM stuff let me look at
that list
um
Let's see we had
okay this is hypersurface okay but by
the way when you're showing these
are these generated from hypergraph
updates or these generated from just
taking slices of the of the Einstein
equation Solutions the first is
generated from taking slight if we're
taking an initial slice the latter are
generated by hypograph updates
okay and do we know which
hypergraph updating scheme is the best
at leading to a successful course
grained
you know
because as I say the the the scheme is
determined entirely by the curvature
tenses right so essentially what we all
we're doing is we're saying we've got
some very simple set of rewrites that we
can apply that coarsen and refine the
hypograph we've we compute the curvature
at every point at every vertex and if
you know if the curvature is higher than
some value we apply a you know
refinement there if it's lower than some
value we would apply a coarsening there
okay
so it's it's a it's a you know because
because the purpose of this is to do was
essentially to do practical gr
um we do it it's a complete kind of
backwards hack if you see what I mean
right so you compute curvature but do
you compute curvature intrinsically
using hypergraph methods uh so if
there's no analytical form of the
curvature tensor yes
and do you get reasonable results in
that case I mean like if you if you
compare it with the case where there is
an article form yes like um yeah and
um yeah I mean we we show we already
showed numerically that you know the
output of functions like Wolfram Richie
curvature tensor which is sort of you
know the at the analog of reaching
tensor for the discrete case that you
get convergence to the right answer
um and at some point I would quite like
to write a kind of I probably should do
this with a student or something a
writer um
a systematic exploration of the sort of
convergence and stability properties of
these discrete estimators
right but this is Convergence I mean
the question of how well they converge
is going to depend on the measure of in
the space of hypergraphs because there
will be hypergraphs on which they'll
probably be crummy convergence the
question is whether the naturally
generated hypergraphs
generated by hypergraph rewriting have
am I not right I mean you can probably
make a pathological it would be
interesting to see
is there a pathological
hypograph on which in fact there's
really a good summer school project are
there pathological typographs on which
there is ultimately convergence but it's
really slow and silly yeah I I agree
it's kind of it's testing the limits of
how how well how stable gr is in in
discrete space-time systems
um right which is which is similar to
looking at the Continuum limit of
employed Dynamics or something like that
and saying that there exists
configurations of molecules such that
the total density is correct and so on
but yet they're not with reasonable cost
graining procedures they look wrong
right but you know in some sense okay so
one way of interpreting the you know the
gr derivation if you know
if you want to think if you don't want
to sort of assume weak organicity of
hypography writing which of course we
have to assume another way to interpret
that theorem is to say well it's what
it's actually saying is
if you consider only causal invariant
rewrites that preserve dimension
uh you know it's preserve Continuum
Dimension then the class of rewrites
that satisfy the Einstein equations is
and you know is is entropically dominant
in that space if that makes sense sure
right
um pathological example you know just
because it's entropically dominant
doesn't mean that it's measure you know
it's measure one right okay but but
there are multiple things flapping
around here I mean one thing is the
the existence of a Continuum limit AKA
The Analog of the circular
thermodynamics but for um for space time
that's one thing
I mean basically the statement that
everything's going to be sort of
reasonable
is like a statement of the second
orthogonomics
so the structure of space-time
I believe sure and an interesting
question is if we want to see through
that to actually see the discrete
structures based on because in a sense
what to the numerical scheme as a
pathology
to the Brownian motion of space-time
Searcher is a success
absolutely
so the question would be
where are the most likely deviations we
have talked about this a bit before
where are the most likely deviations
from
the Continuum limits AKA second
orthodynamics AKA Randomness organicity
whatever all of these all of these
similar Concepts
where is there
where is there the most pathology so to
speak
so my view is I don't know that it's the
most but I think one place that's quite
fruitful to look is um cases where
there's topology change
in the space like hyper surface yeah
um so and a very basic example of that
is in the collapse of a you know of a
rotating fluid distribution or something
so you've got some spinning fluid that's
described by the vowel the vile Lewis
paper petriometric it then collapsed it
then undergoes gravitational collapse
and it it limits to extreme occur
but value is Perpetual in extreme occur
I have different spatial topologies and
so there's some you know in the
Continuum case there's some
quasi-stationary transition between them
and so because they have different
topologies and their vile tenses have
different forms there's a sort of
there's a relaxation time that that
that's that's inherent there where you
know and that's where you see emission
of gravitational waves let me understand
the different topologies what are those
different departures
uh so for I mean a basic one is that
with the extreme with extreme occur you
have these two Horizons right you have
the interior and exterior with values
Papa Petru you only have there's only
one sort of defined surface
but now
maybe Jose wants to comment on this I
mean I think we Jonathan you and I
talked about this a couple of months ago
as well
um
to what extent is this just like a
bifurcation phenomenon where
there was a catastrophe Theory like
phenomenon of one of these kind of um
things where there was an initial sort
of Singularity and then it's split in
two
is that Jose do you know about this this
uh this case not much to be honest
okay so Jonathan I think we talked about
it before and we had some decent
physical interpretation of what's going
on at this place where there is this
splitting into the two you know the
inner and outer Event Horizon right
right what was the physical
interpretation that we had that I've now
forgotten I I can't remember either I
think I think you were the one who came
up with it okay oh that sounds like my
kindest thing but I unfortunately don't
remember
um but anyways but my argument is only
that what we see in the initial
numerical simulations of that is that
the
um
Okay so
the
um frequency for things like the
frequency of the gravitational radiation
that gets emitted in that case
um depends on the discretization scale
of the space time
and so so it's possible we might be able
to see some you know there might be some
observable uh discrepancy between the
Continuum and discrete cases what what
determines the frequency
I don't understand that statement I mean
so you're saying this Tran this
gravitational radiation emitted at the
transition point between the the uh one
and two
during the relaxation phase right so
okay so any any time you have any time
you transition between space times with
different topologies and and crucially
with different forms of the vial tensor
so that's that includes let's say
spinning gravitational collapse but it
but it also includes like you know if
you have two black holes and they
Collide right you've gone from having
two punctures having one puncture
um and the vial tensors are different
um so in that case because you're
transitioning between two different
forms of the valve tensor there's a sort
of finite relaxation time in the you
know in the black hole Collision case
that's the ring down phase
and so on is this not
there's there's some integral over of
the surface integral of the vile tensor
that I mean is this one of these
counting things essentially a
topological counting thing like I don't
know churn classes or or
um
you know any of these other things where
you're evaluating some integral over
some region and depending on how many
holes there are you get a different
number pretty much yeah and we we
actually the framework supports that you
can um if you take
um some Metric tensor objects and you
compute its Riemann tensor which you can
do with the function repository then
there's functionality for computing not
just you can compute it to turn Pantry
Argan scalar you can compute the toiler
scalar and so on and if you integrate
those things then you get things like
you know the the second Churn number you
get the instant on number uh you get you
know the Euler characteristic
okay but let me understand this so so
you're saying
you've put
uh
the
the vile tensor you compute the vial
tensor
and
how should I understand this what's a
simple analog of this I mean if I'm if
I'm going from
simple homotopy type thing where where I
have something which you know like a you
know the the kind of the pair of pants
type situation where you have a cylinder
and it breaks into two cylinders right
what's a what's an example of a of a
thing like what you're describing where
you computer local an integral of a
local quantity and then you see that
somehow change as a result of the um of
a change of the overall topology well if
you take that exact example you know if
you take the co-boardism you know the
the pants code autism example
um and you were to compute the Euler
characteristic of those you know of of
that overall space which is that you you
get by taking the Euler scaler and you
just integrate it over the boundary
um then yeah then you'd see a sudden
transition from that being whatever
two to one or something or you know
there's some discrete transition that
you would see
okay and the claim is that the
gravitational waves
are associated with some you know in
gravitational waves so you're seeing is
bile tensor
stuff is that correct yes and so for
something like a black hole Collision I
mean typically for an Inspire at least
there are two different there are two
different sources of gravitational
radiation right there's the there's the
gravitational radiation from the in
spiral itself it's produced by the
quadruple moment of the of the black
holes yeah but you also get a second
source of gravitational radiation that
is from the merging and that's the ring
down and that's effectively let's say
the sort of the relaxation of the bile
tensor
okay
so
so what are you saying here so you're
saying that if
so
that's that relaxation like the the uh
the gravitational radiation gets emitted
during that relaxation seems to depend
on the I mean if you look so like the
the value that you picked here like you
know whether it was 2.5 or 1.5 the you
know the essentially the the underlying
discretization scale of the space time
that seems to determine uh
some shift in the frequency that seems
to induce a shift in the frequency of
the emitted gravitational radiation
let's just try to understand that
so
and and what is the relationship if I
look at the discretization scale and I
look at the frequencies
is that that there is I mean what you
would naively expect is that there's a
cutoff in the frequencies that is uh you
know that's on the order of
the discretization scale which is
absurdly small
and therefore I mean yeah so there is a
one over the discrete decision scale you
know to the power three or something cut
off
um but you also get a what you seem to
get is some kind of
you know one over scale squared
um shift in the frequency
shift
you know like you know rescaling it you
you see a pitch shift effectively
okay why is that
I mean I'm not sure that I have a good
physical life let's figure it out I mean
so
what's happening I mean in in this
cohortism thinking thing where you go
from the two legs to the one trunk so to
speak
in the merger
you're saying
the gravitational waves you're saying
that that very merging produces
gravitational waves because the far
field file tensor has to change as a
result of that merge is that correct
right exactly
and I mean it's like the classic reason
for radiation which is you've got a near
field like like the classic reason that
a you know an accelerated charge
radiates is because you've got this kind
of Hedgehog of field lines for the
charge sitting in one place and there's
a different Hedgehog shouldn't call it a
hedgehog I mean the the sort of outward
radial lines from another place the
radial lines have shifted but at
Infinity you can see that there's a
difference between the radial lines from
position one and position two and that's
something where you have to somehow
transition from being the radial lines
at position one to radial lines position
two and that means you have to have a
wave go out right to achieve that right
and
I think what you're saying is the same
thing as somehow true here that the
far-field vial tensor is different for
the single black hole as compared to the
two black holes and somehow
to represent that transition there has
to be a gravitational wave that goes out
okay and now you're claiming that the
frequency of that gravitational wave
so in the case of the charges just you
go from here to there
it's just a single
sort of update there's no wave there's
no frequency
right in the case of ring down
what makes there be something periodic
as opposed to just seeing a burst of
gravitational radiation
so my my intuition has always been that
it's it's because it's a quadruple
moment right it's because it's kind of
wobbling in two different accents that's
not for the ring down page that's for
the general Inspire phase but but even
during but even during ring down you see
I mean I don't know Jose probably have
probably has a better intuition for this
tonight Jose with us
um yes
do you can you save us from this male
system of gravitational radiation yeah
okay okay so it's
so to summarize I think this is a bit
like like a bell it we have a
a black hole that has been formed it's
not in in its final State and it has to
get rid of excess of of various things
that that
um
that in order to to relax to to the
final care say and these these excess
things will be immediate as from in the
form of gravitational radiation and it's
a bit like a bell depending on the on
the black hole that we have formed these
things will be emitted with different
frequencies
it has its own I mean depending on the
mass of the black hole we will have at
various frequencies right so Jonathan's
making a claim that there's a pitch
shift associated with discretization
I I can't believe that I mean if we have
a different structure of the space-time
at very
um small scale that will affect probably
the high frequencies part of of the
ground certainly high frequences but
look in the Bell analogy what presumably
affects the frequency of the ring down
of the Bell is the Young's modulus and
so on the Bell
that is how deformable the Bell is
so the question is what's the Young's
modulus of space-time
well sometimes the black hole is is
is
um compared to some some elastic surface
and so we have this surface that is
trying to get rid of of right of like a
bell exactly like like I mean if it's
not exactly
um access metric or not exactly
spherical Forest partial it would try to
get rid of those pumps
right exactly but but that means that
there's a question what is the Young's
modulus of space-time
or I guess more broadly what is the
equation of State for space-time
well it this will be related to the to
the surface gravity of the black hole so
in the end we only have one parameter
right or two it's it's the final
parameters of the black hole that is
going to be well actually but the
critical point is that in our model we
have another parameter which is the the
elementary length
so any dimensional analysis that you do
is going to be blown up by the fact that
there's a new new quantity involved
it's important to mention by the way
actually at least in the preliminary
numerical simulations I've done you see
two effects yeah one is you see the
frequency shift at the high frequency
and you know the high energy end you
also see that the ring down phase occurs
earlier than it sort of should so to
speak if you if you assume the Continuum
approximation
um simply because the the higher the
discretization scale the sooner the
transition happens between the you know
the either the inspiral phase and the
bring down phase or the collapse phase
in the uh bring down well basically the
point that you're making there is
to know that you have a single black
hole
if there is a course of discretization
the black hole becomes a single one more
quickly than if there's a finite
discretization right you can't
distinguish two black holes if they're
smaller than you know if they're
distinguished by something smaller than
a discretization scale right right and
and so so you see there there are two if
you if you do the simulations there are
two discrepancies that you do isolatable
discrepancies that you see between the
uh discrete based on case and continuous
based on case one is just yeah so did
you have a plot of the I mean
you had some kind of plot of this well I
did but it's very old now and I you know
I I want to do a follow-up that looks
specifically at that problem
do we need to blast it with lots of
computer time
I mean that would always help I I mean I
like I ran it on a I have access to
universities if we can meet the Clusters
and things so that you know I can I can
do that but if we if we can do better
somehow then
right well
I mean
okay but you know we're running out of
time here but but um but the basic point
is
I think I understand how these
simulations work
and
the key thing
and our best hope
seems to be
you know some sign of what's going on
based on gravitational radiation of
infinity
that seems to be about the only
I think before we were talking about
gaps between Optical
phenomena and gravitational wave
phenomena I'm not sure
right I mean so what one possibility
yeah it remains a speculative
possibility is that you know we have
some idea of how Photon propagation
Works in a discrete space time we have
some idea of how gravitational waves
work but neither is complete yet but
it's at least possible that within these
kind of multi-messenger astrophysics
scenarios where you have people looking
for both say neutrino signatures and
um gravitational wave signatures or
electromagnetic stages and gravitational
wave signatures that they'll be that
could be observable discrepancies in the
arrival times of those different you
know well let's understand why I mean
for the the point is
a photon
uh
what's the difference between
well I mean one would normally think all
the action is happening at some kind of
event horizon or near some kind of event
horizon both whatever
you know Optical phenomenon there is of
of matter being accelerated to some
ridiculous rate and and radiating
and
gravitational waves being emitted it's
all you know in the end they're all
they appear to be being emitted from The
Event Horizon
right
um
but I mean one huge difference in our
models
is that we do have an internal model for
the black hole
we don't just say oh you know it's an
event horizon and we can't say what's
happening inside we only have an
exterior solution
we have an interior we have a full am I
correct in saying that I mean that we we
in a sense have a full solution for the
complete structure of the space-time
even inside the black hole Yeah if if
you take a sort of I mean again to to
stress these are sort of very synthetic
typography racing systems that have been
engineered to to mirror certain
space-time geometries
um if you take a sort of homegrown
hydrographic writing system though that
contains a transitional black hole then
yes that will you know or the contains a
black hole then that will be the case
there won't be some
you know there won't be some arbitrary
cutoff point where you can't talk about
it anymore
right so one of the questions is
is our kind of Event Horizon porous
in a way that one in Continuum space
time would not be
and if that's the case
is it possible to effectively get
gravitational radiation
if not photons
you know I can imagine a situation where
you can't fit a photon through
but you can fit
something that
essentially forms itself into
gravitational radiation so what's an
example to take an extreme example
you've got a harbor with a bunch of
water and you've got water waves and
they're flapping around on the surface
of the water and you've got a boat
and you could easily imagine a situation
in which you can't fit the boat through
some hole in the harbor wall but you
perfectly well can get these I mean
there's a bad example because we really
need something where they where the
intrinsic structure of the thing is
defined by the water as opposed but I I
get your point I mean like
or maybe one way to say it would be that
sort of gravitons in inverted commas in
in this model by you know by which I
just mean the carriers of gravitational
information are just causal edges slash
events right there is no whereas photons
probably you know whatever they are big
fluffy things likely have some internal
structure and so unlike most quantum
gravity models there probably is some
large size discrepancy between the
photon and the graviton
right or a minimal graviton is um right
I mean
what Aggregates to something that is a
full sort of particle like propagating
graviton
yeah I mean right there's a core to the
photon that defines its quantum numbers
and so on that requires a bunch of
causal edges whereas gravitational
effects happen even down at the level of
a single causal Edge right and so so
therefore there are presumably
obstructions that will apply to photons
but won't apply to gravisons
right in particular the shredding of
space-time there can be a situation in
which that you know gravitational
effects can propagate through but
photons cannot and it kind of reminds me
of this cyclic Universe things
where which which have that feature
don't they that the the gravitational
waves can get through the the the uh
crunch than other things cannot I think
so yeah certainly in like
I've heard Penrose claim that in CCC you
can you know you you can see
gravitational wave signatures from prior
eons somehow I don't well it's probably
the same phenomenons we're talking about
here
except that uh because any
um
well all right this is exciting we need
I mean we got further to go here we're
gonna find you know it's super
embarrassing as we've as you know in
Brownian motion was discovered 100 years
before people understood it was due to
the presence of molecules
and I think we've discussed previously
that it's quite possible that there's an
astrophysical phenomenon sitting out
there that's been around for a really
long time that reveals the discreetness
of space-time and we just don't know it
yet
and obviously the the
best candidate for that will be dark
matter
and perhaps we should discuss a
different time
the use of
these simulations to ask questions I
mean what would it take in this kind of
simulation strategy you know we're
dealing with the extreme case of black
holes what would it take
to uh
get
not
such an extreme case but rather just a
standard you know big black hole center
of a galaxy rotation curve type thing
well I mean for something like I mean
you probably still want to use
schwartsfield or something like you know
I mean like trance Shield is a good
metric even for non-black hole cases
right just the matter
um I mean the rotation curve of a galaxy
we can
naively we could just look at orbits in
the schwartzelt solution
right and and my I I don't I don't know
a huge amount about Galactic astronomy
my understanding is that's a pretty good
approximation like the the you know the
the galactic cores are
some often slowly rotate sufficiently
slowly rotating that Schwartz child is a
good approximation oh yeah I'm sure but
I mean there's also a bunch of look
there's only 10 of the five solar masses
right the center of our galaxy but
there's um on the order of 10 to the 11
solar masses in the whole galaxy
a galaxy is not all ended up in the
garbage can
yeah right
um but yes anyway I mean and there are
again there's functionality for doing
um I mean it's actually quite nice
there's functions like discrete
hypersurface geodesic which is again in
the GitHub repository but not yes in wfr
which essentially reduce solving the
geodesic equation to solving for you
know graph g86 in the in the hypographs
and so you see we can easily so we can
get the orbits yeah exactly but but I
mean the phenomenon that we're looking
for
is
that there is larger effective gravity
associated with the with the external
orbits than you would expect from the
matter
right
and the question that we could ask then
we don't really have a great definition
of matter the only definition of matter
we have is solve the Einstein equations
and see what's there
right
um well we do have a definition of
matter which has to do with
uh
see I know it's not clear because I mean
Dark Matter could be as
um effective in you know if we look at
the um uh Flux Of causal edges
that could perfectly well include dark
matter
yeah I mean my basic position about this
is that dot you know okay
as in in the true Spirit of the
equivalence principle you know the
distinction between what is master and
what is space is not a particular you
know it's not defined a priori right
that's something which we have the you
know we have the the freedom to choose
um
and so you know whatever the Dark Matter
story is in the Wolfram model case my
guess is that it's just something about
you know there's a there's a
there's some feature of space that we
have
you know we have chosen to interpret as
a matter distribution but it's really
you know it's ultimately just some
feature of space right
yes or alternatively put there's a zero
in some kind of normalization
renormalization story there's a
definition of what space is that is
slightly off right right
um but yeah and in a sense the fact that
there's no a primary way of saying this
bundle of hyper edges is matter this
bundle of high Prejudice is background
space is precisely the statement that
you know you can switch any positive
term in the Einstein tensor to a
negative term in the stress energy
sensor and also our expectation that the
vast majority of course ledgers are
associated with knitting together the
structural space not with providing the
things that we identify as matter
right right
yeah
um and and yeah and and that and that
makes your questions about you know
equations of state and space time and so
on quite I think quite well defined even
if you can't even if you don't know how
to answer those yet
right
all right time to um on a very mundane
level there I mean one of the things I
wanted to get out of this was just a
sense of is the the interface to all
this functionality you know with setting
up symbolic metric sensors and symbolic
sensors and and plugging these into
discrete hypers decomposition stuff like
does that interface sort of make sense
more or less but you know I have to say
I feel like this whole thing is very
much at the research phase and the the
uses are going to be Leading Edge
research kinds of things rather than
sort of uh
sort of industrial production type stuff
and so I think that the the fact that
you might have to read the documentation
to figure out what's going on is
probably less important
fair enough I mean my hope would be that
at least the symbolic side like the
these are the non-numerical sites might
be useful you know just as we've seen
with the quantum framework being used in
teaching and stuff that it might be
useful for no I agree I mean this
clarifies a lot of things about how
things work in the I think this needs
another iteration for that but right I
think that that um I mean these things
always I mean even my own little
understanding of ADM and things like
this is greatly helped by sort of uh
concretizing these things in terms of
functions and so on and I think other
peoples will be too I mean being able to
see that being able to see what it means
I mean asking questions like what does
energy mean in the you know in general
relativity we could probably compute
that from all these things explicitly
and see that oh there's a unknown zero
and Etc et cetera Etc which seems useful
right
um I have got to go actually to another
live stream
um uh but uh uh this was a fine
discussion and to be continued and uh
let's go find Brownian motion in
space-time but I think we've still got a
few more iterations to go I think we
should we should talk about this thing
about gd6
orbits defined by gd6 and how that
relates to uh
what is merely knitting together the
structure of space versus I mean really
what we want
is something where
um
where there's some kind of overrun
from knitting together the structure of
space it's it's something kind of not
like gravitational magnetism
it's some
you know what I bet it is I bet there's
something like viscosity in space-time
just like you you can get
or some effect
that goes beyond
in other words what we're you know the
question is
is the identifiable
Mass
in the galaxy
all leads to gravity
I mean the the presence of viscosity it
should be fairly easy to test right
because all we have to do is check
whether the you know the Continuum
equations that describe the propagation
of gravitational radiation whether they
are purely hyperbolic as they are in the
Continuum case in you know the normal
continued case or whether they have a
parabolic damping yeah okay so it
probably there is an ordinary viscosity
because that would actually damp out
gravitational waves right yeah you'd see
gravitational wave dispersion which I
don't think is observed no
that is not
I mean so far as well at least the the
um
uh actually you just see damping it
depends on whether it's both positive
viscosity what the kinds of and
gravitational waves anyway are
differently classified because they're
neither long you know they have
quadrupled deformations
Etc et cetera et cetera
um all right I better go to my other
thing but let's continue this
uh hopefully sooner rather than later
because this was this was fun and
exciting and I think we're getting
somewhere
all right thanks to folks on the live
stream thank you Jonathan Jose
Etc see you all soon
bye for now